how do you get to crypto right and i'm
leaving you a little bit in terms of
uh you've got a friend who basically
kind of hits you over the head a second
time so let me tell that story
as to kind of what pushes you to at
least go explore crypto
and then we can talk about kind of what
you do but just talk through that
process of like how you actually
arrive at okay crypto is a potential
solution
you know when times are good everybody's
busy
you know if you're in love with the
iphone then the answer to everything is
iphone if you're in love with your apple
watch when you're in love with twitter
the answer is
you know that you know um so when times
are good everybody focuses on that and
there's only limited time so
i i think i was closed to the
possibility it's just there's so many
other things going on
and um when uh the coveted crisis hit
everybody got sent home and we all had
to
had to contemplate ideas that we had
previously rejected
and we had to embrace ideas that that
just were very foreign to us so
how do i discover crypto well first i
have a mega mega mega problem
and the mega problem is i have a lot of
cash
and i'm watching it melt away
and i and and i'm i'm helped to realize
i have a mega problem
by this insane v recovery in
the bond market and the equity market
and uh
you know all of the talking heads so
after
after that then i have an opportunity
which is i've got a cash generating
business
and then i've got one more problem which
is
the investors the at the outside
investment community if you go to them
and say
hey we're a great enterprise software
company and we've got all this cash
their answer is well we don't really
value the cash
what i mean because they're smarter than
i am right
now i'm not being i'm not joking i'm
being serious they are smarter than them
they knew before i knew that cash is
trash
and you're a fool to sit on the cash
you're just
if the natural asset inflation rate is
10
it means that every time i generate 50
million in operating income
i burn 50 million in purchasing power on
the cash
and we're just running as hard as we can
to stand still
so we weren't getting any credit for the
cash
we didn't need the cash ergo we need to
do something
and so what is the thing you're going to
do and we started
working through it like what do you do
if you have 500 million dollars of cash
you don't need well you can buy your own
stock back
right there's a limit to how fast you
can do it if you go into a market in a
thinly traded stock and you're buying
twenty percent of
the float every day you know that's
going to take about four years
right it's like you you know if if your
account if your ice cube is melting 15
or 20
a year you don't got four years or at
least you know
inflation is going to do a better job so
that didn't really make sense so we had
we got kicked into high gear like
everybody got kicked into high gear this
year right if you didn't know how to use
zoom
you know like we started we started uh
on a monday morning with one video
conferencing technology we discarded it
i'm not going to say which one
we discarded it for another one by 11
a.m
by 2 p.m we're using zoom by 4 p.m the
ceo sends out an edict
zoom is now the corporate standard
everyone will switch over to zoom
starting tomorrow right that's how and
by the way
the same ceo that said i don't believe
in remote work
you got to show up to the office or else
you're not working for me and i would
have sworn up and down
i hated remote work until covert crisis
hit
flip and so that same idea happened with
the balance sheet
there are all these strongly held views
you got to be conservative you got to
invest in cash and short-term t-bills
and you don't contemplate anything else
and then all of a sudden
you contemplate other things so i mean
you're an expert
you tell me if you had 500 million
dollars of cash right now
where would you invest it uh i'm
cheating because you and i see eye to
eye now cause i'd go buy a lot of
bitcoin
okay and so if you didn't know what you
know
but you were an intelligent person and
you watched
youtube and you watched everything else
what would be your laundry list
of assets to consider investing in yeah
it basically all the inflation hedge
assets right you look at everything from
real estate precious metals
uh bitcoin you kind of just go down the
line hard assets that have some sort of
inflation hedge
type qualities uh that really are more
kind of wealth preservation than
anything would be the
the general bucket to at least go start
exploring with right okay so let's take
through them
commercial real estate how do you go buy
500 million dollars worth of commercial
real estate at a fair
price that's not an impaired asset
by something happening in the economy
right now how many people want to sell
you commercial real estate at a fair
price right now that is not impaired
they all think it's still worth what it
was worth in january okay
so that you know that's kind of
difficult so what's my next thing
go buy i'm not so silly as to go buy
like uh 20th century stock go buy apple
amazon facebook you know twitter
oh by the way back in 2012 i wrote the
mobile wave you know what i said in the
mobile wave i said
go buy facebook amazon apple twitter it
was a good idea
in 2012. if you had done it then you
would have made 10 times your money
very good idea not the same idea
this week right i mean at this point
you know is is apple computer going to
go up by a factor of 10 from here
right maybe it might double it might be
cut in half but you know you're
with the best equity in the world you've
got a you've got equal upside down side
you're really just
there's no asymmetric exactly and so
when you started to look at this
um did you look at real estate precious
metals
and bitcoin or kind of what was what was
the on the menu if you will for
evaluation
i went okay and this is where i got it i
got to give a plug to my friend eric
weiss eric rice
running his own bitcoin bitcoin
investment
you know advisory service you know he's
saying this is what i'm doing and i'm
just dismissing him like uh
whatever this bitcoin thing i don't know
what it is but it's crazy crypto
and shell game so he just
he keeps mentioning it and i keep
thinking about it
and then then one day we're sitting
around my pool in miami
and he starts explaining it and
something clicks in my head
that maybe this is a pretty good idea
you know like
i i have been beaten over the head
with a two by four and so i'm a bit more
open-minded but i started thinking about
it
and then i realized i really got to look
at precious metal you know you got now
you go to the
robert kiyosaki silver gold or bitcoin
you know choose one and so we get down
to choosing are we gonna invest in
precious metals or bitcoin
am i gonna i already dismissed
commercial real estate i dismissed a
market basket of equities the spider
you know nasdaq 100 that stuff's just
not
compelling i you know i tell you what i
want right
what i want is something that that might
be cut in half that can go up by a
factor of 10.
asymmetric payoff by the way that's what
any intelligent investors
that's what you want when you bought
amazon in 2011
that's what you were getting when you
bought apple computer when the iphone
came out
that's what every every rational winner
is getting
you want a 10x upside and then you want
yeah like i can even live with losing
all the money
although here's the catch you know like
every good investment in my opinion if
you're gonna put a lot of money at work
the the winning formula for the past 10
years or 15 years has been
find a digital dominant network
that's dematerialized some some
fundamental thing
the mobile network is apple the
information network at google
the video network youtube you know the
social network
facebook uh even twitter speech network
dematerialize and amazon the retail
network
you buy them when they're 100 billion
dollar market cap
when something hits a hundred billion
dollar and by when they're
ten times bigger than the next biggest
thing
and they're a hundred billion dollars
they're probably going to crush
everything and at that point
like you know i remember lecturing wall
street guys in 2011
2012 about apple you know and here's
what they said he said
well we know you love apple and and you
think it's going to
beat the world but you know our idea is
if apple goes up too high we're going to
sell the stock and we're going to buy
hp so we can dell so we can diversify
your computer portfolio
and then if and if all your tech names
if apple and amazon and facebook go up
too much
we're gonna sell those so you don't get
too much in technology
okay and my answer was what you know
if you think about it broadly there's no
example of a successful company in the
history of the world
that wasn't a technology company
standard oil was a technology company
if you go and go to hershey's factory
you'll find they figured out how to
manufacture 50 000 candy bars in a clean
room and it's the most sophisticated
piece of technology
you will ever see in your life you think
they're not technology companies you're
just ignorant
there is no there is no winning
investment in a company that's not a
technology company
at their time general electric there's a
time
when electricity was interesting
technology
boeing same thing before we could fly
so so the idea you sell too much tech
is a foolish idea in my opinion the idea
that you sell apple when it gets too big
is another foolish idea
like well there's never been a company
that was 500 billion in
market cap what or or trillion right
they're people saying that
there's never been a company as valuable
as apple
because there's never been a company as
valuable as apple
and another way to say that is there's
never been a company
that could create a software camera
change the way it works and ship it to a
billion people overnight for a nickel
and if you could actually ship a product
to a billion people overnight for a
nickel
you could create a lot of value with no
cost so
obviously these digital networks
facebook
apple amazon you know you you could see
them they're all around us
they're they're insanely um
value generating but there but there's
another dynamic here which is the
network effect right metcalfe's law
it's like as soon as as soon as
everybody uses facebook
you know you can't how do i get
257 of my closest friends to switch to
the next thing
it's really hard like twitter
you know how do you get all of your
followers on twitter
to switch to the next speech network you
think you know even if
you know even if a guy has a massive
following on twitter
you think he's going to switch you know
to
another thing probably not he's gonna be
the last person to leave
so you you know you're buried in
concrete there
so now we come back to bitcoin
okay the the number one knock on bitcoin
uh for the outsider is well it's just
software someone else can copy it
and i think bitcoiners they don't do
themselves justice here
i mean sometimes i think the exchanges
and and some of the others they over
promote the fact that there's
237 different crypto pairs you can trade
right and and if i've done that it's
like that
it's that long tail where all of a
sudden there's
one thing and i want to have a list of
47
things but but you know what's an
epiphany
you know the epiphany is when you're a
young ceo and you're like i'm going to
put a sales person in every single
state in america there's 50 states 50
sales people
there's an epiphany when you go to new
york city and you realize that half of
all the money in the country
is in one city and then you realize that
maybe you're being captured by orthodoxy
so in this entire crypto area
it's it's great to have all the
innovation and it's good to experiment
with this and that and defy and
maybe that'll work and maybe that'll
work or maybe that work but to the
outsider
the outsider you look at it and you're
like well what if everybody moves their
money off of bitcoin to the
to ether or to whatever or to yoyo coin
and you know and they stop and
and then someone puts this language
eight pages of language
in front of you what happens if there's
a hard fork or a soft fork
you know how debilitating anxiety
inducing
that would be to get to deliver eight
pages of legal disclaimers on hard fork
soft fork
risk like you mean like my crypto can
float away
and they get all the anxiety written so
you got to get beyond that
okay and but it's easy to get beyond
that the easy way to get beyond it is to
say
look this is a proof of work crypto
network designed to be a store of value
and the only thing we're going to do
is maintain a constant store of value as
a digital gold
and we're going to expand huge amounts
of energy
to protect that network and upgrade that
network and you can take
your 500 million dollars out of the bank
and put it on a network and everybody in
the community is going to spend
every iota of their energy to make sure
no one
f's with that network